bitcoin was off to a fast start in 2022
but it might not be in the direction
that we all wanted bitcoin facing one of
the worst monthly declines to start the
year in a long time let's first take a
look where the hell are we with bitcoin
sitting around 38 000 which is up about
four percent over the last 24 hours
which by the way is much better than s p
500 gold silver euro yen renminbi or oil
we can then go ahead and we look at the
bitcoin stats themselves you can see
that bitcoin's inflation rate still
sitting at 1.77 percent over 90 percent
of the 21 million bitcoin have been
issued still with 12.9 billion dollars
of bitcoin settlement volume in the last
24 hours the bitcoin miners around the
world have been paid 35 million dollars
over the last 24 hours to secure the
bitcoin network and of course bitcoin is
down 43
from that all-time high of 69 000 but it
is up 16 almost 17 percent from this
recent cycle low if we then go ahead and
we look at bitcoin compared to gold and
the s p 500 it's all green baby minus
gold over the last 12 months but one
thing that we haven't seen in a long
time is actually over the last 12 months
the s p 500 has actually outperformed
bitcoin s p 500 is up 18 over the last
year bitcoin only up 12. if you then go
and you look at any other time period on
this graph bitcoin is absolutely
dominant of both gold and the s p 500.
if we then continue and we take a look
and we say to ourselves well what about
bitcoin's price itself and that closing
price well bitcoin has spent only 284
days in the history of the digital asset
above where it is today it's about six
percent of bitcoin's life has been
higher than 38
763 at the 40 000 price level only 272
days above that price point as well if
we then go and we look at the compound
annual growth rate you can see there
that bitcoin growing still even with the
price decline at 140 percent over the
last 10 years that 10 per that 10-year
compound annual growth rate of 140 or
more compared to the s p 500 at only 13
and the nasdaq at 17
bitcoin remains the superior asset to
hold when you look at that graph now of
course bitcoin's rough start to 2022
shouldn't cause concern but it is
important to understand what's been
happening bitcoin's decline was about 18
in january of 2022. it's the worst start
to a year since 2018 when it went down
29
and it also follows december of 2021's
19 slump bitcoin has only had 11 days in
january where it was up so about 65 of
the time
bitcoin was going down in price and you
can see here didn't look so hot for
bitcoin holders now that's okay we know
the asset is volatile and even with
these challenging months you can see all
the way back through 2017. yes there are
plenty of months where the price goes
down but there are also plenty of months
where the price goes up and so you've
got to be able to zoom out you've got to
be able to understand that maybe you
shouldn't be making investment decisions
based on the 30-day performance of any
asset whether it's bitcoin stocks or
anything else and then we've got this
quote here and in this quote what we see
from troy geiske the chief market
strategist at fs investments he said
crypto is a very volatile asset class
and i hope that everyone participating
in that market is aware of the
volatility potential it's a much
trickier environment than it was six
months ago 12 months ago 18 months ago
where was green light go now it's yellow
light caution well troy might be onto
something or maybe he's not but
understanding where bitcoin is
understanding the difference between
price and fundamentals realizing that
bitcoin still has about a million daily
active addresses it's still settling on
chain not on exchanges 12.9 billion
dollars in 24 hour period and miners are
still getting paid about 35 million
dollars every day to secure the bitcoin
network and continue to put it as the
most secure computing network in the
world the fundamentals and the price
have diverged and ultimately what we
have seen over and over and over again
in the past is that the price and
fundamentals have to meet again that
could be the price coming back to meet
fundamentals where they are at all-time
highs or that could mean that the
fundamentals end up degrading away and
meeting price lower but ultimately i
think that's the big thing to watch here
fundamentals have diverged from price
and when they meet again the big
question is where are they going to be
i'm not changing anything i've been
doing for the last couple of years but
make sure you're educated make sure
you're looking at the data and make sure
you understand exactly what's happening
with bitcoin